are you an economy with performance  issues if it's hard to achieve and  maintain growth maybe stimulus is right  for you take stimulus once every  election cycle or whenever you're in  need of economic enhancement economies  would top-heavy debt loads and high tax  burdens should not use stimulus stimulus  has many active ingredients but they are  poorly understood by economists side  effects may include hyperinflation  stagnation dollar devaluation earmarks  excessive debt bankruptcy loss of jobs  growth of welfare state expansion of  nanny state unrealized expectations  economic impotence depression ala ptosis  and sweaty palms stimulus has not been  proven successful so it should not be  used in the hopes of achieving actual  growth stimulus because Paul economies  have performance issues  [Music]